here yo what Popp and it's your girl
scarb and check me out on the bootleg
Kev podcast let's get it about to get
into another interview brought to you by
my bookie it's holiday season that means
bowl games NBA in season tournament NFL
all going down let's make this money
right now if you sign up at my bookie
and use my promo code bootleg claim your
deposit match that's right put a deposit
in up to $1,000 they're going to match
it
mybookie.ag promo code is bootleg let's
get to the
interview bleake C podcast special guest
in here representing the Bronx scar liet
is in the building what's popping what's
good it's crazy cuz I I first saw you
the first time I saw you was uh you were
rapping with the with the hot dog
hanging from the string yeah and I was
like yo this sh this [__] is crazy and
then my uh my boy TK who's one of my
Engineers we were riding around and he
was like yo if you heard of Scar lip and
I was like nah and then he uh he played
one of your songs and I was like this
[__] is crazy and then he showed me your
inst I was like oh no I've seen her you
know what I'm saying and so I've been a
fan ever since so it's been dope to see
you just kind of like being extremely
original in a era of unoriginality in my
opinion you're like a one of one right
now thank you I appreciate that yeah how
long have you been rapping I've been
rapping since 2016 is when I like
publicly started rapping but I always
did like a lot of poetry and stuff so I
say around like eight years now I've
been rapping so yeah yeah yeah for you
like uh what was the moment in which you
realized like this is something that's
worth like continuing to pursue like oh
I might I might make it you know I mean
I might be able to make some money off
this yeah well I knew it when I dropped
Gizzy gobler cuz that's when I got the
most interaction and it was like
everybody like little booy shout out the
little booy he reposted me and was like
should I sign her and stuff like that
and I was just like oh [__] I could
could really make it in these streets
with these balls you feel me like I'm
about to keep going did Lil booie try to
sign you no he just made a post like
okay I don't know you know he's he
signed you know he had the young blue I
mean that didn't work out the greatest
but you know boo is boozy he's a legend
yeah like he was like he shared it it
was like should I sign her you know he's
one of the famous people uh you might
have met some famous people that were
you know that you grew up idolizing MH
I've met a bunch that uh were not who I
thought they were boozie is exactly who
he is on the internet like when you meet
boozy you're like oh right this is great
this is exactly what who I hoped booie
would be right yeah he's have you met
him yet um I don't met him yet no I
didn't meet him yet well we just had you
do a freestyle you killed this freestyle
over one of his Beats so ready should go
check yeah that's actually my favorite
song of his so I love that song for sure
uh coming out of the Bronx give me kind
of you you said 50 is your favorite ever
your goat 50 c my favorite rapper DMX my
favorite rapper I love Eminem too like
well shout out to you know it's crazy
cuz I do feel like what is dope about
you is you're extremely vulnerable and
when like cuz I've watched all a lot of
your interviews I watched your Vlad
interview you're very honest about like
your life you've had you know obviously
a very very um interesting come up to
say the least but I think that you have
kind of like that DMX vulnerability
about you that not a lot of artists have
these days cuz I feel like when I was
like listening to DMX as I felt like I
felt his pain and [__] you know what I'm
saying like is that important for you to
like make sure you kind of like very
very upfront about everything in the
bars and your life and all that yeah I'm
like a open book you feel me I just want
somebody to talk to for real so I just
do it in my music like hoping like
somebody understand me you feel me and I
see like a lot of people relate to me
and understand like growing up people
didn't really relate to me they say oh
she's depressed and stuff like that you
know what I mean but I'm just happy like
to just speak about it cuz they be like
oh she's depressed she's crazy da d da
no what what if I'm just sad you know
what I mean what if I just need somebody
to talk to you feel me like yeah I'm
going through [__] my mom just died
obviously I'm sad you know what I mean
so it's just like putting it in music
everybody relate and everybody can feel
it and I feel like I'm not the only one
so it's like people be like yeah she
makes me feel like I'm not the only one
but really they make me feel like I'm
not the only one you feel what I'm
saying yeah for you like do you have you
have you had fans reach out to you and
be like yo you kind of like help me get
through this cuz I I watched one of your
interviews and I just like God damn like
this is so crazy cuz there has to be
people out there who don't have the
means or like the you know the ability
to kind of like vent to somebody you
know what I'm saying who maybe watch an
interview like yours or listen to some
of your records and like really can't
relate like have you had fans reach out
to you like that yeah a lot of my fans
reach out to me they just be like you
inspired me so much some people be like
I wanted to commit suicide and they be
like they heard my song suicide
awareness and it made them want to keep
going that's and then just young girls
around the world just be like I look up
to you scar like I could relate to you
yeah and that makes me keep going
believe it or not that's like damn like
people really need even if it's like one
person one person but it be a lot no but
I'm saying like that's it's crazy cuz if
you could affect one person's life let
alone however many you know thousands
you know what I mean yeah even the even
the [__] I used to beat
up they be saying scar you want me to
keep going shout out to them yeah were
there a lot of women used to beat up I
used to [__] these [__] up well for
what though for disrespect to me various
reasons various reasons various reasons
but you know what anybody you regret
[__] up like damn I I really was
tripping that day I really that didn't
deserve a ass beating you know I feel
like everybody deserved what they had
coming okay so it's safe to say you're
nice with your hands yeah yeah uhhuh you
ever have you ever took the L on the
other side of I got beat up I got beat
up a lot of times on a one-on-one or a
jump one on
on I got beat up on one-on ones many
times and it's always I'm always
fighting the big [__] I'm never
fighting no little bit the BBWs yeah no
I'm just talking about big [__] like
like WNBA like bigger than me you see
how I'm big Rebecca Lobo who's that uh
she's played for the Liberty back in the
day but yeah even the [__] I beat up
even the [__] that broke my heart they
be proud of me now
today uh you how many times have you had
your heart bro
broken three times three yeah how old
are you
22 that's not terrible that's not too
bad um what was the mo like for you like
was it
cheating this dude left me for a white
girl oh that's rough when I was in job
corpse damn Hey listen I'm white and I
don't even [__] with white women so I my
wife's Mexican my baby mom is Mexican
I I I've never ever partook in the in
the white women so yeah he's tripping
the one thing you know listen the one
thing about white women though is like
all my friends like I have a lot of
black friends today white chicks and
like for the most part um they are very
like uh they're they're the most
gullible idiotic women of all time like
I wish I wish I had it in me to date
someone who reminded me of my sister or
my aunt or something I like white
[__] they fun yeah they're fun and
gullible and kind of you know God bless
them you know they uh they definitely
signed the tax money right over you know
what I'm saying
they sure do um so so that was was that
the last guy who broke your heart the
last dude that broke my
heart was a dude from Jersey but I'm
over that [__] now for real for real in
real
life I don't even talk to these [__]
no more wow I can't even walk with them
no more do you feel like um because
you're a new bubbling artist you have so
much stuff going on that like it's
probably do you think it's like a good
or a bad thing to have a relationship
right now just have fun girls have fun
and focus on on Fus on your hustle just
have fun later you got to focus on
taking over the rap game exactly
100% don't do it don't do
what don't do what yo you funny yo um
talk about your your friendship with
Buster Rhymes Buster rymes obviously is
uh one of the greatest of all
time yo shout out to Buster he he bought
me my first diamond chain that's sick
yeah he B he he bought me two Diamond
chains nobody know that I lost the first
chain yeah when Buster ROMs bought me
that diamond chain he replaced it yeah
he replaced it so you told him like
spent the bag yo I got a crazy story to
tell you what happened so bust up RS
buys me a diamond chain right okay I
lose it performing with him in 50 Cent
on stage okay at least at least you
didn't lose it in I didn't lose it from
no reason I was on the stage I was Buck
Wilding by sck Flex yeah sick FX yeah I
was like Buster I lost the chain he was
like what how how you lose your chain I
I was on stage it just fell off yeah he
was like that's not my fault because
like if I'm on stage performing it
that's the jeweler's fault or whatever
but we [__] with the we [__] with the
jeer so what happened was he bought me
another chain and nobody knew and I just
acted like I never lost the chain same
chain same chain same chain right spent
that bag wow but then it's going [__]
your head up the dude came like listen
so mind you I lost the chain and he
bought me a new chain right
then Buster RS was performing at a show
and some guy just came to him and was
like listen I found the chain like I
know this means a lot to scar and you
and I know how important this chain is
so I want to give it to you so now you
got two so now I got two chains yeah wow
shout out to Two Chains check you out
shout out to Buster ryes crazy crazy
story yeah were you are you nervous
performing like on stage with Buster
Rhymes and 50 Cent yeah man I'd be
[__] my pants it was too much people
bro and I was just looking at everybody
I'm just like man I got to kill it I
can't [__] they show up yeah cuz bust is
like one of the greatest performers of
all time if not the he's like top three
for sure yeah he might be number one I
love Buster arms the way him and uh and
spliff be on stage and they do the thing
where like he turns them down and he
starts rapping all quiet and then he
turns up yo SPL mad funny bro no it's
crazy best hype man of all time yeah no
it's crazy everybody who never if you
like ever want to watch a live hip-hop
show and like take some notes go watch
Buster Rhymes perform um so what's going
on I know you got the new record that
just dropped uh the the Blick record
obviously no statements is going crazy
is album on the way what's what's
happening with the
project yo Blick is out right
now but we got a remix coming top of the
Year who's on the remix I can't tell you
that the way you just looked over there
was like should I say cuz I was like
even confused if I was able to say that
like
what's this Snoop saying that huh who we
got a we got a remix droper top of the
year with your favorite rapper Who's my
favorite rapper I'm curious if you know
M I don't know who's your favorite
rapper but just know he's your favorite
rapper Who's on the record I can't tell
you I'mma tell you after the interview
I'mma wh what city are they from I can't
say that cuz then you're going to know I
won't know unless they're unless they're
from Charlotte and it's the baby the
dirtiest part of the trenches
what state can't tell you y I'm not
going to let them figure it out from
[Music]
Chicago Chicago shout out to Chief Keef
though it's not Chief Keef could it be
is he from Chicago yeah all right good
could it be little Dirk no but I [__]
with little Dirk man shout out to Little
Dirk I hope we we get a song dirtiest
part of the trenches Southern trenches
Northern trenches the dirtiest part
oh nasty nasty just the F Chester
Pennsylvania have you ever been to
Chester Pennsylvania it's it's not good
but look so we got bit coming the remix
the remix with a visual with a visual
then we got a EP coming okay can we talk
about it yeah what's up when the EP
coming the ep's coming
next year I mean obviously it's
December the EP is coming next year okay
and the EP is called scars and Stripes
oh I like that lots of
features stuck
with you just can't tell me okay I can't
tell you shout out to my grandom I
didn't wear a bracelet today every time
I wear my gom's bracelet it means I'm G
to be protected and she's with me that's
dope I uh my dad has a godmother I don't
have one I don't know do you have like
is your godmother still with us she
she's alive oh she's alive good for her
[__] I got to ask I don't know are you
like have a good relationship with her I
love my godom so much she's like my
second mom you know uh in uh like uh
where I'm from in Arizona there a lot of
uh you know obviously my son's half
Mexican and uh I noticed that a lot of
uh my wife's and my baby Mama's Family
they'll pick someone as The Godfather or
the godmom and then they end up beefing
with them weird and then it's like
they're just like Gone With the Wind
it's like oh yeah that's your godfather
but [__] him you know can I say
something I feel like God moms don't
really get appreciated a lot you feel me
cuz it's like they're literally for you
when your mom is not there like my mom
you would hope so of course yeah yeah
well my godom yeah she's like there like
as a mom and she just hold a lot of like
baggages for me you feel me like so she
stepped in and held it down she stepped
in yeah that's dope that's good shout
out to God Mom man um who would you okay
how about this right now there's I I my
my two favorite movements going on in
newor New York are you and the uh 41 the
41 kids uh I love those guys man and and
shout out to Jen she's she's killing it
um have you guys worked together or you
guys I feel like it'd be dope if you
guys did some [__] together y i I love
they they they so lit and they're so
positive they're just having fun they
ain't on no [__] like yeah they just
Good Vibes you know what I mean and like
we if we work that's going to be
amazing yeah if we work if we work we
was in the booth and [__] we we played
and [__] that's good yeah who's uh who's
your like
uh bucket Le bucket list feature that
hasn't happened yet because you've
already worked with Snoop and I mean you
I mean that that's a big deal oh that's
the realest [__] Snoop Dog the realest
the realest [__] like you don't even
know that [__] put me look he jumped on
my song yo Snoop Dog is the realest
[__] mhm he jumped on my song he broke
brought me out to you did you go to did
you go to his compound in uh Englewood
look yeah he jumped on my song No I know
he brought me out to the Yankee stadium
for free no
charge and he did it with no hesitation
[__] be funny with that [__] what do
you mean he brought you like to perform
with him at Yankee Stadium yeah he
brought me out to perform I love Snoop
Dog bro dead ass that's my [__] in real
life and he's also the same we don't got
to talk every day just for me to right
[__] with a [__] you know what I mean
like he was just a fan like how did he
even find out I I'm a fan but he just
loves my song this is New York actually
what happened was I dm'd him yo listen
this the LA this is La re all I do is DM
people I just be dming these [__] the
people that I don't think I would ever
even be able to work with right I be
like you know what let me just try and
you got to take a shot everybody the
people you would not imagine listen bro
the people you would not imagine I got
songs with is the ones I got songs with
because you dm' them just because I dm'
them I think most artists have like too
much ego to like want to reach out it's
like bro just shoot your shot like bro
I'm talking about [__] you watch you
be like I would never be able to get
that that's fire so that's how it
happened with Snoop was a DM yep just
sliding in a DM listen artist if you
hungry enough you want to make it your
biggest resource is your DMs I know you
didn't uh you don't smoke weed but um
you didn't smoke with Snoop oh no I
didn't smoke with Snoop yet there's a
few guys like I smoke with Snoop I don't
smoke but for Snoop Dog I I feel like
snoop's one of the few guys who like if
they pass you the joint you're like I
mean [__] it it's Snoop I know his [__]
gonna have me Zed up what up y'all
bootleg Kev here shout out to our family
at Imperial extraction listen right now
oh a free 2 G pre roll of that zah of
that loud of that gas can get right to
your door delivered for free now now
this is what's dope about uh Imperial
let me tell you man the thing about
Imperial is they got 16 years of
experience when it comes to this West
Coast cannabis space and recently they
just got into the hemp scene now what is
the hemp scene that means uh that it's
it's legal it's going to get delivered
right to your door federally legal it
ships to your door no issues uh and this
is what also is dope about it it's still
going to get you high it's going to get
you blown just like that uh traditional
cannabis it's that
thca um look they got so much stuff
going on um this is the thcp enhanced
live resin you can get your carts there
they got all the flavors boom boom most
importantly whatever you do Imperial uh
make sure you go to their website
because uh look Imperial extraction.
comom if you go to that website and you
use that promo code bootleg you're going
to get hooked up with a free 2 Grand
pre-roll right now Imperial extraction.
comom get yourself I've been smoking
these for uh about three weeks now and
man I love them and um they definitely
get me elevated man and and this is
what's dope about these let me show yall
just real quick if you guys don't know
um Imperial extraction let's pop one
open because this is what's getting
delivered to your house for free
remember imperal extraction. comom promo
Co bootleg at
checkout look at that thing man it's a
two G pre-roll with the glass tip
premium thca and it's got the diamond
infused uh joints in here you bust this
thing open there's little diamonds in
there bro it's crazy all right it comes
with one and a half grams of that top
shelf flour half a gram of the pure thca
diamonds and it's free yeah so uh go to
the promo code bootleg at Imperial
extraction. comom and trust me when I
say you will not regret it shout out to
Imperial extraction also want to give a
shout out to our good Folks at Blue Chu
that's right salute to the family at
Blue Chu make sure you head on over to
blu.com use that promo code bootleg
right now if you don't know blueo is
where it's at they're getting you
situated real nicely when it comes to
your penis your Johnson your [__] oh
that's a that's a weird wait who says
[__] I don't know nonetheless if you're
dealing with the rectile dysfunction if
you're dealing with a little anxiety
little stress and you're not up to par
when it comes to Performance look you
need to put your best step forward when
it comes to your dick game you know what
I'm saying so what you need to do is go
to uh blue.com use the promo code
bootleg right now they're going to give
you a month supply for free
now if you're watching this you don't
know about blue let me explain same
exact active ingredient as Viagra and
Calis in a chewable form deliver to your
door discreetly yes no doctor's
appointments uh none of that it's all
online you don't have to worry about
going and sitting in an office and
waiting to go get your dick pills no
listen by the way these aren't dick
pills these are this is a chewable you
know what I'm saying let's just be clear
there's a difference this is much better
um blue chw
promo code bootleg month supply for free
delivered to your door
discreetly all online it's what we're
doing man same active ingredients
viagran SE Alice man get your dick right
all right let's get back to the
interview yeah yo they love that word in
New York Z yo how crazy is New York
right now you could just buy weed
anywhere uhhuh you smoke on the corner
you can smoke you could buy weed there's
like a dude with a fold up table on
every corner selling eights it's [__]
the Wild Wild West you won't even go to
jail no more for it it's legal and they
got stores like if you go to the store
now in New York you like they have
[__] jars of weed behind the counter
they're selling weed at the store I
don't understand what's happening you
want to know why I don't smoke weed no
more why all right so let me tell you
this story mhm don't judge me you got
too high no my dude I was doing weed
popping pills all types of [__] okay
terrible I say that right yo you've said
a lot in your interviews for the record
I've watched a lot of them I used to pop
perks okay I used to pop perks every
like a lot a lot like I used to just pop
perks cuz I was just depressed like I
was just like I need some A coping me
mechanism yeah like I need to get high
like I need something to get me going
like and then one time I popped like
three of them at once and I was walking
and next to you know I just woke up on a
[__] porch oh [__] than God you weren't
driving thank God I wasn't driving bro I
could have died bro for sure I woke up
I'm like how the [__] did I get here
were you doing like perk 30s I was
popping and locking and dropping it hey
man Pop Lock And droing
so that's why you wait why you stop
smoking I don't smoke weed no more
either cuz when I smoked weed one time
it was a [__] standing right in front
of me like you we talking we vibing just
chilling and [__] like that smoking that
weed getting high feeling good and know
he was like yeah yeah yeah and then you
know I take another puff and then I lift
my head up and turn my head to the [__]
and you know how you standing right here
it was three [__] but it was one
[__] I swear to God it was three of
you and I'm look I'm talking to the
niggaer right there how many hits did
you take over there huh how many hits
did you take I was just smoking you
might have been that might have been
angel dust inside of that joint [__]
man I just stopped doing these drugs
completely tripping me out that's good
but now I'm clean good for you I'm clean
no drugs pills are terrible yeah I don't
pop pills no more and the thing is the
pills is making my stomach hurt yeah and
then it's hard to get off of them and
then nowadays you never know you might
[__] around now people going to think
I'm a drug addict no you're clean I'm
clean but not with you but how they know
that I'm going to be clean well people
need to know that like you know I think
there's there's people who who maybe are
trying to get off of pills it's possible
look that fentanyl be hitting
[__] these days so you know you
you definitely got clean at the right
time yeah I stopped all those drugs um
for you has there been a moment um you
know obviously you you're pretty
transparent about the loss of your
mom um you know for you you talk about
like is there any advice you would give
to anybody who has to grieve and still
has to try to get through life when it
comes to getting through such a a
traumatic unexpected loss you know what
I mean considering the circumstances
people can do their research but is
there any advice or and cuz I mean
that's that's a rough thing to get
through and push yeah like and the fact
of the matter is it's going to be hard
getting through it you never you're
never really going to get through the
loss of your mom like you're never going
to just completely get through it I
never did and I'm still trying to get
it's always going to be there like that
hurt that feeling that emptiness that
loss but you just got to just keep going
and find a way to cope through it and
just like don't let it break you don't
let it make you go crazy don't make it
don't let it make you stop going cuz a
lot of [__] they lose somebody they
love and they lose their self they lose
their mind and you got to just like
really put up that fight to just be like
all I'm not going to lose myself like
that [__] going to hurt me and I'mma
grieve and it ain't going to 100% heal
ever but I got to keep going and some
people got kids some people got things
they want to do in their life like you
got to keep going if it's not for you
let it be for something else you know
what I mean 100% yeah I had a friend of
mine recently who lost this kid
unexpectedly in a car accident and I was
just like dude I don't even know [__]
go crazy if I lost my son I don't even
know what I'd do I would probably I just
feel like I would just disappear
somewhere I don't know that's why like
that's why I just keep the people I love
feel me and I just be like
like you know what's another good thing
though like being voices for other
people mhm you know like other people
that's going through the same thing like
being you're kind of like the voice of
the voiceless a thank you yeah yeah um
who who do you listen to right now not
not like your alltime greats but like
who's just like some music if if we were
to open up your Spotify or apple music
like what did you do your your recap
like your personal recap like who were
your top five I don't even stream music
I I listen to music on YouTube I don't
stream music that's the crazy part yeah
a lot of people are like that like I
don't know why YouTube doesn't do a
recap yeah I don't stream music on on um
those things but I do stream music on
YouTube and so what you listening to I
listen to um of course my playlist is
like Drake do cat cardi
B ice Bice I listen to a lot of Billy
eyh Billy ish shout out to her yeah
that's my I love her Billy Alish is fire
yeah I just be listening to music on um
on YouTube and stuff YouTube and stuff
you know who I like right now that's hot
in New York this guy he um bro hold on
let me talk bro moving stiff when he
walk I think it's j hound and J5 that
sounds like what you just did right now
sounds like so many New York rappers
hold on Yo am I crazy you can can you
give me some insight
here I feel like there's so many rappers
who just sound like pop smoke now not
like
the way they rap or what their but their
voice it's like there's so like like we
went to New York we hung out with Dusty
Lan he sounds like popm smoke and he
knows this he's the homie free Dusty
loane uh what was the other guy Ross
swish sounds like popm smoke so it's
like is this like something in the water
where everyone's got a [__] deep
raspy voice it's crazy you know what I
think it's just because Us New Yorkers
we talk away so it's like if you hear
somebody from
Chicago or something and you'll be like
oh they all rap the same or something
like that it's not that they all rap I'm
not I'm not saying that I'm talking
about their voice their voice their
talking voice I mean I don't know maybe
it's something it's like it's crazy bro
it's like now shout out to them though
because they really be putting the city
on uh you got a lot of big homies in the
rap game we already talked about Buster
rymes uh any other uh guys who have you
know obviously embraced you and given
you some some game um yeah a lot of
people like I don't I got a 50
Cent shout out to 50 Cent what 50 tell
you you teach you how to be Petty
pettiest [__] alive right there
I love it I just study his the way he
like he's just a genius you feel me oh
he is I think he's going to buy Revolt
from Diddy by the way that's my
prediction it's going to happen I just
feel like one day we're going to wake up
and Diddy's going to own or did's going
to sell Revolt to 50 I don't know we'll
see I just think he's that kind of petty
but you know any body else besides 50 oh
yeah I performed at Revol before shout
out to that that was a fun experience
hopefully not too fun and Revol them
people in Atlanta they was [__] with
me too I was like back the [__] up move
the [__]
back bootleg Kev here hey shout out to
King pom man we want to show them some
love uh listen I've been I feel like
enlightened recently uh since we've been
working with King pom man the cleanest
smoke organic all natural no tobacco and
this is what's dope about King pom is uh
um they have these Turpin infused tips
and what I love about them is whatever
flavor you're into like these are the
red rain energy drink flavors I'm big
energy drink guy right so you stuff what
you need in these bad
boys hit that tip you're going to get
hit with a nice shock of flavor boom
that's the uh pink lemonade also these
are the natural boys but I'm going to
show you what it looks like rolled up
all right let's take a peek in here we
got the king pom boys
here this what we're doing all right now
if you go to King pom.com it is the
holiday season you want to take care of
somebody you love you want to take care
of yourself you deserve to be taken care
of yo 50% off right now use that promo
code bootleg it's either 50 or 40% [__]
I probably should know that I think it's
50 though either way it's 50 or 40
bootleg king pom.com or you know go to
7-Eleven they got them uh at there any
of your smoke shops in your hood
whatever it is wherever you're at pull
up to your smoke shop get you some King
pal one more time organic
flavor no
tobacco it's lit also can we show some
love to our family at harden man shout
out to harden man look if you're in
Vegas you got to pull up you got to say
take me to hardine right now I need to
go to harden they're going to take you
they're going to get you situated Hardin
Las Vegas the best cannabis uh
dispensary I've ever walked into in my
life the most craziest selection of
Premium cannabis in the entire world I
mean that place smells like
God's uh sweat it feels it just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Hardin Las Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to Hardin
vegas.com and when you're in Vegas make
sure you pull up to harden baby yo what
but but who else besides 50 though um 50
Buster
Rhymes who's the people that like gave
me
love I'm trying to think who Mary Mary
Mar J blig oh cardi be like if we going
to talk we going to
talk card's so sweet she's the best
she's a real [__]
yeah who else like I can't really like
come up with [__] like I think cardi B
is like a
booy um oh what you saying my bad I was
just going to say cardi B is like
somehow you know she's I I don't know
she's just like in her own territory of
like like I don't give a [__] at this
point if she writes her raps or not she
might like my favorite rapper female
wise I don't know like maybe ever first
of all she be delivering the [__] out of
them bars trying to play with her like
that like no I'm saying she's so fire
shees she like like last year she had
like the verses of the Year times three
cuz she's that [__] like the tomorrow 2
verse I mean it's just like every verse
crazy every time she gets on a record
it's [__] it's a home run yeah I'm
trying to get her on my record cardi
what's up that's the uh remix for Blick
right that's the remix you always like
from the From The Trenches right the
Bronx of trenches right yeah yo I'm from
the dirtiest part of the
trenches I we were in the Bronx and
where were we at we're in a housing
project we thought we were going to die
for sure uh we they hanging out with who
we hanging out with yo you know what I
like about La people who's a funny guy
from the Bronx who raps but he's also
funny oh he's on
Tio oh yeah you know what shout out to
him
yo I was about to say I like La how
people dress people dress really nice La
they fly as [__] how do people from La
get their style like when I go you could
go to the the they just dress so good I
think it's cuz it's not that cold here
you know what you right but I actually
feel the opposite cuz I feel like out
here you really can't wear no [__] for
real because it's [__] it's hot they
got style in LA but you guys have Tims
yeah of course you know you got to walk
through the snow yo guess what shoes I
got on today y'all Rihanna Savage Fenty
some Pumas with the fat laces with the
fat laces have you ever like like do you
wear timolin a lot that's a New York
stereotype for sure I always wear Tims I
wear my um ups and I wear um there's
like a way to tie them like my boss uh
one of the guys I work with he's a
legend in the radio game his name is Doc
winter he uh he ties his Tims like super
tight and it's like really frustrating
he ties him like like he's about to run
you know know what I mean like I feel
like you got you there's like the way to
wear Tims and there's it's the one way
you don't tie them right like do you tie
your Tim you know it's going to be bad
for you what do you mean if you fight a
[__] and they got you get jumped and
they got Tims on it's over for you good
night they violating you they going to
stomp you out and them them Tim they
going to [__] you up and just going to
leave you bruised and bro broken you
sound like you've been on either side of
that we done seen it we don't didn't
been through it had it happen made it
happen all right so you guys we have
Skid Row in La lots of homeless people
everywhere it's wild I was in New York
recently it was kind of refreshing to
not to see so many homeless people but
what you guys have is a lot of [__]
just interesting times on the subway
yeah what is your craziest Subway
story I don't have a craziest Subway
story with other people but the crazy
Subway story I could remember is when my
mom was alive and we was on the um train
and my mom got off the train and she
thought I was with her but then the
train closed but then I was like m m
like cuz it was somehow like she got it
to open again and then I went oh okay
okay they was like yo that girl almost
lost some That Girl Meet the nextop yeah
damn I was scared as [__] I was I don't
know how old I was I was in New York and
I fell asleep on the train and I woke up
in the Bronx I was supposed to get off
like I think like in Harlem or something
where I wasle the I knocked the [__] out
and I was like oh and then I got off
stop playing it was like 2: in the
morning it was really late you could you
know what you could be butt ass naked on
a train ain't nobody going to pay you no
mind in New York cuz you just playing
that's true we don't pay no mind that
New Yorkers you guys mind your business
list New Yorkers mind day yo find your
business yeah yo almost like it's a good
thing but it's also a bad thing cuz I've
seen people like getting [__] up and
people just walk by like ain't my
problem it's kind of scary because it's
like it's scary though because it's like
a girl will be getting jumped and nobody
and nobody will do nothing or they'll
record it or some [__] nobody will do
nothing they just put on World Star yeah
put it on wallar and be like damn why
didn't nobody help so we're going to get
a new we're going to get a new EP in the
New Year the Blick remix coming soon
with cardi be um yo no it's no it's not
now with Dirk uh
you know what let's speak it to
existence yeah why not I wish you would
just tell me the state I'd guess it I'm
not going to do once I say the state how
about this tell me the state and then
I'll guess and you can say no can't do
it for you so it's got to be a r Wait
wait wait it's got to be a random random
state it can't it's got to be a really
specific State then cuz if you said New
York I'm not telling you all right
you're going to tell me off the camera
I'm from a place where we don't do no
rting [__] just tell me what
happened you like that song yeah I love
I look no statements my [__] what you
like better this is New York or no
statements this is New York is my
[__] you know why this is New York makes
me want to like commit a felony and what
does no statements make you want to do
it makes me want to commit a
misdemeanor so the thing about this is
New York is it gives me um it gives me
like when I was a growing up you know we
had a group group called mop from
Brownsville uh Billy Dan and Lil Fame
and their music made me want to like go
outside and and like punch people in the
face and your song this is New York made
me want to like physically assault
somebody for sure so you know like that
song makes the fact that a song could
really make you want to put hands on
somebody yeah like that's really good
like I mean there's songs that make me
want to sell cocaine shout outs to the
clips you know yeah but it's like this
is New York make you want to put hands
on [__] for no reason yeah it's good
workout music you got hey you got some
[__] workout music bro but no
statements really like but you could
work out to all your [__] like even what
there no statements in the uh in this is
this is New York it's like workout
[__] playlist yo how you feel about
Blick I like the Blick record I want to
hear who I want to see who's on the
remix who's on the
remix I can't tell you we got to wrap it
up you got you got other [__] to do
you're you're you're busy all right
listen EP on the way freestyle go watch
it it's on YouTube too Scarlet I
appreciate you thank you for having me
shout out to Bootleg Kev she didn't
remember my name now I remember you and
that's all that matters that's all that
matters shout out to my man's right here
100 Grand he was with me when I was in a
can understand I wasn't I wasn't there I
don't know shut up
okay there we go appreciate you guys
watching hey this interview was brought
to you by Odd Socks baby the holidays
are here and the people who you love
deserve the fly socks the most
comfortable socks in the world oh these
Scarface socks oh look at these things
look at these Top Ramen socks what are
we talking about whatever you're into
WWE Scarface uh The Godfather [__]
Transformers Power Rangers Ghostbusters
Breaking Bad uh Coca-Cola hello you know
I mean they got the socks for them and
they are the most comfortable socks in
the world get some odd Soxs Basics on
your feet and than me later odd Soxs
official.com use the promo code bootleg
save 20% off at checkout for the holiday
season appreciate yall watching